some people thought that I was a skeptic
that's actually not true I I'm asking
detailed questions because I want to
know what was the error like on this
alien ship I want to know what did the
glass rod feel like was it heavy was
Gravity the same and so on I'm curious
to know about Skinwalker what's going on
at Skinwalker and what's its connections
to
what's its connection to UFOs when you
go looking
for the phenomenon uh it basically
doesn't show itself fascinating with
Skinwalker is that
um you basically have the convergence of
multiple you know things happening and
their cattle are missing or cattle
mutilation where blood is gone a lot of
like really weird things about it like
maybe the cuts are in between cells
maybe there's no vascular collapse maybe
it happened within 10 minutes I mean
lights in the sky Poltergeist events
were all happening there